you ready fry today I'm talking to
Constantine cooler head of the German
FDP party's National Youth Organization
welcome to our show mr. cooler thank you
a coolest Akula you're only 28 years old
you've already completed two state
examinations in law and are a newly
elected delegates of the German
Bundestag between the two of us there
are so many nice jobs out there why did
it have to be politics well the good
thing is I learned a different
profession first I'm a lawyer by
training I might not have worked as one
for long just for a while
after my second state examination but
it's important to me to have a
profession I trained for you never know
your term in office only lasts for four
years and it may well all be over there
but even if it is there will be other
options for me but for now it's great to
have this opportunity at 28 I mean the
average age of Bundestag MPs is about 50
so being able to contribute at 28 is a
real gift a great honour but you laid
the groundwork early on you joined
Germany's Young Liberals when you were
only 13 other boys that age usually
spend their time in front of a computer
or at a sports club
what on earth drove you into their arms
at 13 possess me good question I did all
those things too I checked out a Sports
Club gamed on my computer tried out
acting private tutoring I tried all
sorts of things but somehow I always
felt they didn't give me a chance to
talk properly about the things I was
really interested in and that I wasn't
really being taken seriously as a young
person and then thanks to internet
connections that finally reached our
village
I discovered politics because of the
forum's run by the FTPS young liberal
group I ended up joining their you could
discuss politics and that really grabbed
me I met people there who took me
seriously they treated me as an equal
and the enthusiasm that triggered in me
still hasn't faded it's the kind of the
guy's the wall and redundant he was
worth unhurt after school you went to a
private university to study law where
public university is not good enough you
know there's a great public university
in girding and right by where we lived I
think Laura is a subject you can study
particularly well at public universities
and it means you can meet people
studying other subjects not just law
only law students convinced me was its
international focus we had to spend one
trimester abroad I went to Paris and the
support system for students post a
little different there but I quickly got
a sense that you could really achieve a
lot if you had the necessary ambition
and that really appealed to me but I
don't think you necessarily have to
study at a private university what's
much more important is really knowing
what you want to study and once you've
decided on a subject you have to figure
out which university don't just blindly
choose a private university that's not
the way to go about it
you're very young and very career-driven
that fits well to the FD P's image of a
party for high earners one that it was
actually trying to shed what makes you
so different from the Liberal Party
members that were voted out of
Parliament in 2013 well I know that you
could think that looking at my resume
but ambition and career orientation
aren't necessarily negative per se I've
always made a point of trying out
different things and long before
completing school when I was 16 17 I
spent a year in South America as an
exchange student in Ecuador I lived with
her family there went to a local school
and spent a lot of time learning Spanish
and meeting people who had a completely
different perspective on life I think
that taught me to be a bit more relaxed
about the whole question of being just
career oriented or not it was an
exciting time just like my time in
France was so I can't really accept that
criticism because I have always been
aware of life outside of Germany and
even Europe and I think there's
combination of I'm interested in foreign
cultures I'm interested in foreign
languages on the one hand as well as an
understanding for the way economics work
on the other is what has always defined
the FDB party but I also don't think you
can judge a person's character just by
their party membership I think that's a
stretch glabrous is no special girl I've
been known
too much labeling yeah absolutely I read
online that the FTPS political guiding
principle is freedom whatever the
circumstances does that mean freedom in
the face of state opposition pretty
early on I began to ask myself why the
Liberal Party why the FDP
and when you trace it back of course it
because of what the Liberals rested from
the states bit by bit in the 19th
century freedom of opinion freedom of
the press
taking that sentiment and transferring
it to today's world the question arises
how much video surveillance
how much telecommunication surveillance
is acceptable in an age when we spend so
much time online that is an important
point to me when it comes to
informational self-determination because
if you feel like you're being watched
24/7 you will change your behavior
without even noticing it that's not what
self-determination is supposed to mean
that's why yes in the worst case
informational self-determination must
also be asserted in the face of state
opposition take major corporations think
of tax evasion or social networks
they've created a public space that has
practically replaced real public life
then autonomy must also be defended
against the private sector that all
sounds great but it's difficult to do
take climate change which is a bone of
contention for the new German government
coalition talks there the slogan freedom
whatever the circumstances isn't going
to get you very far especially when it
comes to voluntary commitments nothing's
happened on the Paris agreement it's
disappointing isn't it
poisoned water yeah what now it's
disappointing that the debate on this
issue is being argued very narrowly
everyone agreed to the climate goals in
Paris and rightly so anyone who takes a
different approach to measures is made
out to be the bad guy I don't think it's
that simple
above all we need to understand that in
regions like the one I'm from rural
Lower Saxony other measures are needed
then in the cities under master
malnutrition there's two measures
include state intervening yes of course
it had been much too easy to say our
climate policies could be summarised
as freedom whatever the circumstances
that would be stopping short of the mark
we have a program for climate policies I
honestly have to admit I wish the FDP
would take this issue a bit further
sometimes feel the FTP is a bit too
silent on environmental politics and in
how they communicate to the public I
hope that the coalition talks will help
us to see that the environment can also
be an issue for a liberal party though I
wouldn't say it's my favorite issue I'm
more interested in domestic and legal
affairs as well as European politics but
the FTP still needs to drill deeper into
the subject of climate policies either
way freedom or state we are wrecking our
planet mr. cruller isn't it finally time
to fix a date to phase-out combustion
engines we're happy to talk about dates
but this state must take into
consideration that there's a difference
between rural and urban areas and that
it makes a difference whether this state
is set by the state or if engineers who
understand the technology much better
for example than I do say this is the
date we want we also need to consider
that in constituencies like mine there
are communities for whom it makes a
difference if I say II mobility or if I
say the combustion engine will be
allowed here for a transitional period
it's great that we can talk with the
Green Party about how long this
transition period might last and the
environment definitely needs to be
factored in by asked to the Green Party
has just taken its demand for a fixed
target off the table
what's your response respect that and
think it's a great concession from the
Green Party I would want my own party
and the party leadership to respond to
this concession with a concession of
their own but that's all I can say about
it because I'm not part of the answer
negotiations on the environment so I'm
not in the loop but I find it incredibly
decent of the Green Party to meet us
halfway like that and I hope that we can
respond in kind and not gloat like the
CSU did saying oh well it was an idiotic
demand in the first place I just can't
understand why the CSU did that that's
not how you reach an agreement on
details come back that's all got money
to them
you hinted at it earlier freedom or
state do you think paying taxes is a
good thing well when you look at your
pay slip or do your tax declaration then
your first thought usually is wow that's
a lot but when you look at how the
country works and how we want a
functioning police force and a free
education system with universal basic
services then sure taxes are a part of
that the question is how higher the
taxes what incentives to these taxes
provide for example for research or for
education haven't we got an awful lot of
people paying out for 50% of what they
earn in taxes and social security
contributions a system in which people
who work very hard have to pay so much
and that's why we've worked out changes
we want to make in tax policies the
liberal parties and against taxes but we
need to talk about the way they are
structured some of your supporters would
disagree do you accept the fact that
there are lots of corporations and very
rich people who find legal loopholes to
cut their taxes right there when it
comes to major corporations evading
taxes I agree they shouldn't be able to
earn massive amounts of money here and
then avoid financing the common good
there are also some interesting models
proposed by environmentalists that's
nicely said but there's nothing you can
do if Malta Island the Netherlands and
Luxemburg keep saying no well we have to
have a serious talk about the advantages
these states get from the free movement
of capital for example they have
advantages and operate their business
model on the basis that capital that
they want to keep there can be
transferred anywhere to be invested and
that advantage has to be linked to
certain issues and that's where we have
to talk about taxes I think a lot of
what Emmanuel macron suggested for the
European Union is worth considering why
doesn't Germany enter into negotiations
with France on tax policies I think
that'd be a good thing his initiative
shows that it is possible to consider
new ideas in Europe so maybe this new
window to have this conversation with
France is an opportunity to change how
major corporations evade taxes to the
weak
mr. : there are so many things to talk
about but
afraid our time is up so to close our
interview we now come to our open
sentences and ask you to finish them for
us what I like about for say Hoffa is
best when he actually sticks to his
positions and what I don't like about
the Green Party is that's how they
gloated when the FDP lost all its seats
in parliament in 2013 deep units munis
talkers SPD parliamentary group leader
under analysis an interesting person I
would love to have a coffee with
sometime as long as she doesn't smack me
one afterwards in 20 years I will be
happy hopefully Lucas Constantine cooler
thank you very much thank you